mass is windows awesome star his
knowledge is knowledge and trace
rox ben darth this is losing loads of money
and 5% of the levels and bel20 5% is that
mass and the 70%
dark energy citizen which are visible
this is kinda strange because it's
suggested everthing who  experience is
really
and more to the friction for hennessy
briquet house drove him nice clew that
massa and the energy hd work
booyah exactly show week 6 fem so
your i know
[music]
doc massa is the staff that makes it
possible for can access to  just one week
and great war the device is proud to be
worth
i quickly became driver's license just not
enough domo mass
the gravity exchange mass is not strong
enough to form galaxy centcom place
structures
set is becomes bowline greenpeace gray
robbed price and still form galaxies
zoey near  with something els inside' and
the edges me something the thousand a
meter of reflex light sand finger doc
bloods besides being able to calculate
the existence of dat massa can seerd
find of
genesis we de high concentration the
alkmaarse bent like nothing made by
anyway there something Vader interact
with gravity
right now we have my this badboy dark
energy is still the murder is is how you
peck the alkmaarse is no child left know my
world star  they are soft with
particles the ice cold but she
is nuts and team az peck centimeter
budget is unique camera is when
reaction with naoh molar mass
each but she is also south-north made up of
black holes
very compact objects coercion and effect
at surroundings  blue roof mass themes
with care between oh leuven te price
basically leonie know everything social
housing
sometimes things are always two pints
rights which gravity 3 distant is a
lasso a day but she is problem stage
of complicated x if i particle the
thousand interact with light and  the crowd
and your baby i'm sorry why one must have your
vote no data manager is equally beautiful
strange and mysterious week eldest pulls
the weekend with zipper and three conte  st ash
bowie deduce ferry clothing
in 1920 standards edwin hubble i are my
heroes live live online to be measured by
distant comics is
shift towards the red-handed
electromagnetic spectrum
there is travels to respect the fun with
finger mo distant galaxy's
shirt along the great red  shaft
monastery comics is still so margin
hubble the language in the this was plus 3 the
us myself is expanding
the law shifts cross it's the
wavelength of light if ironing asia
cross experts
moby's and to purchase reception and
the expansion of the whole house is
accelerating
the preset the prologue gravity
whitcross expansion toe earth slow down
or even your tracks end caleb's in
ourselves the some point
c1000 change the prophetic experts
let's just more love is here space is
wreath and i feared everywhere
galaxy is up-tight bernd crassus of
stuff
help together by gravity sorry dance
experience this expansion and how they
realize publishes heavy weather anders
my wedded e  r is empty space in a house
where is forming every second
so dark energy seems to be some
everdingen els in the us combined
we him motor blythe's abattoir dark
energy maite maite there is the dark energy
is another fine the just a propos tf
specs
empty space is knows nothing is he
sit energy
i can generate more space and this
concept chef like the  here verse expand
i go peter charles the more more
smash-up do you have many often apps and
death race 2 fixed
expanding innovation drawbar idea is close
to ride earlier einstein her belly in
1917 the concept of a cosmology
constant and according to the hedge rate de
force  or gravity
leonie problem is the mummy trajectory your
camp
bbm ativ s energy the result we are
afraid and when we get this also the
confusion and not right there is the
interest spaces extra info  left and gray
virtual particles that spontaneously and
continuous uniform redemption and
ben disappear internet in game free energy
of luis particles capital know
jean-paul maybe dark energy is an
online grinder timing energy floyd of
many good primates t shale house
with get he is the one on  is the effect
of the universal normal energy a multitude of
bodyfit accessed through them know how
and where or i'll be herd pulls sex so
far was silent and later questions to watch
a 11 there is about marching dark energy
and still josh
series under fur house business  card er
frustrating when the hand
this is frontières science went along very
exciting choices the masses how much you
feel the edge of things i still very much
something with smartphones from the riley fresh
island in space
the clients hide wonder in
hollywood ver is so macho guts too  lean
and 5 this or share this video i
supported by the australian academy of
science which promotes and supports
xlens in science
loud more baptist i had one the others
like this the furniture that also he
here and we are blue stuart with him
his coaching goes at site a videos and
rose and made possible by your support
and night show will come
if you want to support has  and become
powder the coach salt the barony
check out a page van beek
[Music]